i ragazzi e benvenuto questo video sono
famiglie
scusatemi periodi in bombole in questo
video sanremo ci si sentirà 20 volte
però la stanza vuota non sono a casa mia
però posso registrare soltanto qui
avrete quindi perdonatemi l'audio siamo
ragazzi su un gioco fichissimo che
appena uscito me l'avrebbe dato tanto e
io sono un tipo tutto gasato ed è
fighissimo perché così questa roba come
al sicuro e proprio nel gioco magnetico
la catena dimostra la storia ci dice
questa questo pezzo di plastica che si
trasforma nel gioco in una vera e
propria arma e chi è una figata
incredibile mi sa che rimetteranno anche
un diritto così però per adesso ci
chiamano estate portò bene che della
limitazione ragazzi vedo che ci sono i
chioschi figli io sulla mia bellissima
non mi fanno incazzare è che quando ci
sono sono carico a molla della laga sto
tornati come xx secolo roma tutto visto
ragazzi giuro che farà qualcosa che ha
scalato il muro l'ho vista è andata su
il fatto che cosa che tu possa avere
l'arma così migliaia di maniera ma
raramente in mano cos'è casa editore
ragazzi è esattamente quello che penso
no dai ha fatto parte 1 magnificamente
nara di ore dedicate davvero ok era un
gioco bello prima per la rete
l'unica mano norme entrano iraniano che
sera no se sollecitata dalla lega non ci
crede veramente
ma tra tutte le cose umana dei pomeriggi
ma quando la ma siete noiosi nella vita
ragazzi mi sto pagando in mano non so se
sei abilità foggia era di schifo
fra dato uscito web porca vacca line
ragazzi non posso continuare di eurolega
no mi fanno entrare nelle camere non mi
fanno incazzare
non mi batte in casa si fa assicurati di
registrare tutto è il sovraccosto
registrando io dico facciamole chi è
questo ciao
c'è una bugia d'epoca che schifo va bè
ragazzi un pò l'obiettivo è trovare
continue perché ci siamo a schiantarsi
su questo pianeta che non si sa come
abbiamo fatto a schiantarsi e non lo so
neanche io davo a schiantarsi su 30 di
iphone in o pianeta di rami o la vagina
dell'ama dei leaders vuole le cattive ne
prevede niente tassa della settimana fa
dove l'hanno pesante di
ce li avete altrimenti ci sono 13
direttamente messo altri nemici
ora che ne soffriranno e se la rete
elezioni non vogliono iran i grossi
facciano altri tipi proprie attività
mettete le catene su un cammello quei
ratti qualcosa di figo non è sempre
garantiti i giochi o incredibile
selezionato successo allora ragazzi si
stanno affidando lontano perché questo
andrà avanti così è
ma poi quello che avete per capire chi
sono io ripeto basta
avevo detto no ragni giganti quanto
succedere che famiglie quanto se quanto
sede etico di oggi nella morte generale
non ancora piuttosto vago ragni grossi
che grossi cazzola vulcano o stavo
scherzando certa ironia la conosci
l'ironia ironia farfan provvedimenti o
che esplodono dopo ma dovete essere
tanti nomi date fastidio 5 punti dalla
società e schifosi ma quanto vanno
limitati con marinella fanno corpo
militare
va bene abbiamo scherzato demolito
io che ho nessuna di queste però che va
a stadio tanto basta
qui sono groupies toloi cosa a casa da a
massimo da me tregua
ok contro l'arci la formata da fatelo
averlo tanto trambusto pianeta invece
nel nostro piccole bombe atomiche e
l'avrebbe fatto un buon lavoro
basta regata pallamano da dimaro quanti
sono spesso scorso a succhiare di sabre
beigua
ma guarda è la cosa migliore che mi è
successo finora la palla migliore di
raggiungere sabina sono contento le
posizioni non funziona non ha mangiato
che si è successo
porca [ __ ] non dovete prendervi
giovamento dal mondo di queste robe
cazzo come portanova grossi questi
vostri e rimane la stessa roba
costituire sabbia
grazie ad esso sinistro dipendente
oppure perché prima andando in bocca
malissimo ma mi spiegate perchè mi sto
del pratico vulcano soprattutto
soprattutto perché parla invece di
concertate comunque io quest'animale
aggiungerei anche nella vita reale
andreani e tanto per dirne una si chiama
morto nel monte palco dobbiamo
distruggere l'anello
a posto dov'è dover che non posso
offrirti cosi dovevo lo posso che
sparare bisogna altro non lo vedo più
l'ho perso
mi fai vomitare ai a qualcuno misteriosa
e quello grosso pezzo
eccolo
come che non mi è piaciuto questo sito
terminata ragazzo liberty si no non lo
sapevo
va bene basta
ragazzi miei gesù medaille è migliorata
la situazione nel tempo l'unica pelle
però via via vi sia piaciuto bello sarà
fedele lo sapete fare cosa in questi
giochi variare i nemici o per non hanno
usate anche gli stessi nemici ma che non
siano ragni quindi ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto come senso che è piaciuto
il momento non mi piace anche vari
social come una descrizione sono serviti
fischiatemi ci svegliamo nel prossimo
video
[Musica]